[Music]
it's
a look patients get in their eyes
wouldn't be an episode of grey's anatomy
without opening up on some cw flavored
mara duration geez that's a thick clobby
teardrop
maybe get that checked i mean if you get
through this whole bomb crisis
you shouldn't be crying snot from your
tear ducts what's the one thing you've
always dreamed of doing
before you die holy sh you dream of head
and
shoulders commercials too also staring
sexily at the camera in an episode of
grey's anatomy cliche
i'm all for helping each other get sudsy
for hygienic purposes but these car
sponges are far
too large to get into the crevices use
your hands for hygiene
okay hello clearly not my dream
then how do you know the dream is
happening and how are you narrating in
it this is the strangest and most
invasive form of
blocking i think i've ever witnessed
someone [ __ ] up the acting prompt for
this scene and told this guy to emulate
the feeling when you realize you have to
go to the dmv and renew your car tags
but first you have to go pay last year's
property taxes because you're an idiot
and forgot
who wears a towel into the shower a
woman who can turn over on the left side
of the bed and magically appear on the
right side of the bed
is absolutely someone who can put their
hand inside me wait i mean
during surgery of course the man i love
has a wife
i feel like we just covered this
emotional plotline oh around
11 episodes ago for the love of anatomy
why are we still on this
at least we know derek will make the
correct choice and stay with addison
and we won't have to deal with this
coupling for the next several seasons
until he dies a horrible death also
known as getting shonda rhymed that is
what happens right
right you know i can't remember the last
time we kissed
well then he's obviously not that mick
dreamy is he
i have a feeling that tonight's gonna be
a good night or is it a feeling you just
can't stop or is it more than a feeling
or did you flash dance and then think
what a feeling
you gotta be more specific meredith ah
sudden wednesday adams
i know when you were gonna get the good
case i'm gonna let you stay in bed envy
i really have nothing clever to say here
i just wanted you to hear how annoying
this is
dr montgomery shepard is examining her
cervix sir i can see that
do we blame the hospital for forgetting
to pull the privacy curtains before a
cervical exam
or the men who are gawking through the
window unchecked by their peers
the answer is yes bailey's in there oh
bailey's back
that's excellent this being happy
bailey's back sequence goes on for some
time
i'm shocking i'm shocked that you can
still speak after all that screaming
yeah me too is your hand touching
anything hard
so we're gonna find out that hannah has
had her finger on a potentially live
bazooka round this entire time
and if she moves her finger or really
any part of her body it could go off
so in the ambulance ride over the
transfer of the patient into the
hospital and then all the way to the or
you're telling me she hasn't moved a
muscle
because i do not believe you they want
us to evacuate
evacuate did they say why uh no but your
pager said code black
why is it only the head surgeons who
seem to know what code black even is
if it's that important of a situation
wouldn't the interns be made aware of
this as well
anybody want to evacuate going once no
one twice
three times this has got to be the
strangest auction i've ever seen
we are having pre-op patients
transported to mercy west for a
situation they were trying to keep on
the hush hush dr weber's choice to
loudly announce all of this in a crowded
area seems odd i mean i'm guessing he's
not wanting to alert
this guy you know what i think george i
think meredith and christina
are doers i've had surgeons oh she meant
to get things done
my answer still works we watch we're
watchers
keanu reeves was a watcher so don't sell
yourselves too short yes this seems
productive
and i'm sure it will end well i haven't
had sex in eight months
and 12 days i'm horny i'm half naked and
i'm saying yes you want to stand there
and talk metaphors you want to literally
take off your pants izzy would be
extremely proactive at tv sins and then
shortly after fired for sexual
harassment
dr shepard there's an explosive device
in the or next door with the way this
episode has gone i'm honestly not sure
if he's referring to the actual bomb or
karev
where exactly is my husband
he's with my husband now that would have
been a much more interesting storyline
than anything else in this episode
hey everyone the shades are open so come
on down and watch person hear horrible
news while giving birth
no curtains in this hospital we share
all pink mist
excuse me that's what the bomb squad
calls you when you blow up
you're liquid there's nothing left he's
fine uh careful
why don't we get mrs carlson a cup of
coffee ah yes because nothing sues a
broken heart quite like a rush of bitter
hospital grade caffeinated coffee
perks you're right on up i should look
on the bright side
insurance money it's not like this can
get any worse oh
well let me see if the lion episode is
next you hear me i'm holding it in
i'll have him tomorrow just me pep
talking myself in the public restroom
when the deuce wants loose
is it normal for someone to pack a hair
dryer in their go bag for
baby birthing i'm not judging i just
don't understand how that makes any
sense
or did she panic back that doesn't seem
very bailey to me hannah
where's the anesthesiologist he left
it should be noted that unlike most big
name guest stars christina ricci is
giving an honest to god good performance
here
there's a reason it was deemed emmy
worthy enough for a nomination and it's
also
100 sin removal worthy also we wouldn't
dare play the music but just wanted to
point out that the episode is titled
it's the end of the world
and is choosing to play a michael stipe
song that is not it's the end of the
world you had one job music guy
what did i do but if meredith replaced
her hand where hannah's was then that
would mean there was at least one second
or two that no hand was on the live
round and it didn't explode but let's
just ignore that and have another hour
of the exact
same scenario also nobody has been
breathing for this guy for a hot minute
so
he's dead
i had to make a bomb morty i had to
create a bomb hey you know what else we
poke fun out music videos
some shits have sins too trust me and
we're more than willing to point the
counter at the taytes the beavers the
billies and many more check out music
video sims
today
barbie doll sold separately dr shepard
doctor doctor i'm supposed to be calm
look how calm i
am we're just here to use the bathroom
then we're just gonna leave i hope
that's okay
what do you mean is your hand touching
anything hard
are you flirting with me going once no
one twice
three times congratulations to this
lovely young lady at table six you have
won breakfast in a private tennis lesson
with our head instructor brandon